alright let's not go with D for this
time we play d4 land last time or two no
thanks my opponents saying that they
just killed the stream do I believe that
let's see but they're gonna throw on me
d 6 yeah all right let's go open
Sicilian let's see how things are
different with this game on Knight f6
now a 6 there you go so now let's try
especially to there's g3 there's Bishop
e3 let's try that
okay no what now what yeah I know
exactly what I want to do here don't I
that's why I'm moving so quick and I
know exactly the theory on this move for
I got to know move six I got to move six
I have to start scratching my head OOP
seven what should it be okay is f4 move
Bishop e2 what Queen d2 there we go I
think h6 is a good choice um if h6 is
played and I play back to h4 I'm in
trouble I'm in a place called trouble
maybe Queen d2 wasn't the right idea
this is wonderful stuff little bit watch
this guy fumble through the opening he's
great at fumbling in the opening ok well
I better just take the night right you
go here you get killed for time there
goes the precious dark squared bishop
everybody loves giving up the bishop
after seven moons don't they oh oh is my
opponent really considering taking with
the pond ruski oh oh oh power of
suggestion take with the pond ah ok wait
a second my bishop is licking his chops
his chops at what what is he thinking
about you know what he's thinking about
follow the mouse that's your hand so
what's the significance of having my
bishop on each five well a pins this
pond of the king be it prevents this
pond from advancing and allowing for the
bishop to make up make use of this
diagonal and
um well that's enough reason isn't it
let's roll this guy is going to turn to
be a giant Thor and I think and if he's
attacked I think I could do something
that looks reckless but i think is very
effective namely g-form I think I castle
now our weight if I castle Knight takes
Queen takes Queen see five hits my queen
and Bishop what I would like to have
happen is the Queen's to be maintained
and my bishop to be able to sit here I
feel like there's some attack should I
take the night pawn with the Ponte I
wouldn't take the night look at this
tsunami of ponds is my opponent gonna
take with the pond get this cocky look
at this guy this guy and e4 is gonna
he's going to drowned and these black
pawns right here Wow pawn takes or queen
takes another big decision this should
always draw a lot of your attention
whenever you have the opportunity to do
what to change the structure so now of
course like a queen side castle however
should I be doing something instead of
that like first f4 so that I mean II
five with f5 and this Bishop is kind of
crunched I play f5 I believe this
bishops going to have to go off in this
direction what about FF for right now oh
man decisions look at the decisions here
I week in my dark squares can this
Bishop get active not really seeing how
could do that let's go f-for my bishop
on each five is a giant pain and another
thing this King can't cast a queen side
so easily how do you defend against f7
this guy right here is the MVP so far
let's castle if my night is hit I might
want to just throw my night right here
this Bishop is a think
tall pond I think I'm going to run with
night here typical ID and the Sicilian
PSAC open lines towards the King as a
result tempo on the Queen although many
times it'll be played when there's more
pieces on the board so I don't know
should I have actually played a three
just play my rope here next I have to
keep in mind that when the Queen plays
to this fifth-ranked my bishop is hit
I'll pretty much be responding g4 if
that happens and it's kind of a with g 4
i'm saying you know what I'm never going
to come back in this direction and now
let's just play here so now actually if
pawn push night here can't be taken why
not I might want to go here unprovoked
yeah before here takes takes discover
check i'm on the Queen so that can't
play that can't play they can't be
played so ok now now I believe there's
big trouble here big trouble sneaking in
here f6 tricky night on c7 be four is
hit I think this is undefendable this
night is just a beast oh but I didn't
expect that one I could take this pond
down and then this one do I take this
one now because then the bishop comes to
life I think I take this one I'm hitting
the clean tempos I can take this one
next threaten this pond I don't want
this pawn to move if this pond can't
move this bishops dead tricky nights
fairly tricky nights time situation
about equal I might want to give up my
my bishops hit but I'm on this pond I
think this is a TKO time now because if
this pond goes this night is going to be
jumping in here this is to pawn
advantage now I take here pond push I
take here with check and only then take
on d5
this is falling apart now but a closer
look back I believe will reveal that age
5 by my opponent is better than the move
chosen I forget what was played exactly
but before I had the opportunity to play
Bishop here I think pushing here for
black would have been best we'll see
about that though okay now now what is
the big story here the big story is I
have a giant grip on the position Bishop
here trade lightscribe bishops jump a
fantastic night into this position I
could do that right now or play first f5
I like doing it right now I don't care
that this pond could exchange and maybe
this is accessible I just want to be
assured of a good night versus a
not-so-hot bishop okay oh this bishops
getting excited over that right there oh
but wait a second to queens now come off
checks okay time time time where are you
at oh what a bug okay let me do this
just take within my pond watch over that
King position my king wants to sneak up
here
I better challenge that rook right now
oh the rooks gonna get active I think
Brooke activity my nights watching over
the pond just get out of their rope
let's get up here my king is going to
have this let's watch over this
everything defended now better King
position take with the rook did it
really matter okay i have this now time
just make sure that pond doesn't move
King position get my majority going
right there right here this is a passed
pawn okay time time time time pawns on
light bishop is close to dead it's dead
no time watch out for stalemate that's
my last fear just get rid of that night
or that night that pond you know what I
meant you know what I meant with that
they're get this one cut him off coupons
no stalemates no stalemates my opponent
get a stalemate on me the one time I
think so watch ah not too confident here
with uh keep talking about it first it's
a mouse then it's a mousepad it's going
a little slow also it's not the same
when I'm streaming either so all these
different factors good game been koji
let's hit the rewind no that's not
rewind that's rewind let's flip and
let's see about that h5 move age five
okay um well firstly I think my
suggestion is for myself I shouldn't be
going with this if I don't know like
what I'm doing maybe I should go with
just a bishop mover so I don't know
maybe I shouldn't even be playing this
all together but I think h6 was the
right idea this Bishop movement I mean
age six is picking up the bishop again
Bishop here knight takes Bishop takes
Queen Knight takes Queen I'm pretty sure
I'm just down upon their with that line
so anyhow once it does get into this
position why not just take with the
Queen I don't know what the drawback is
with just taken with the Queen it's
probably best but I still see this
capture as being quite alright for black
but stopping Bishop h5 this is something
I had to feel the pain of myself so I'm
not just coming up with this right now
I'm just recalling games where I've
taken beatings and it pretty much
started when I allowed my opponent at
one point to play the bishop they're so
considered the one reason to stop is
just because I mean I'm sure you felt
how annoying it was on this diagonal but
also again you want to get this dark
square Bishop out and I think this is a
wonderful diagonal be getting too
because then you're going to make me
think twice about castling queenside are
you not my queen and king being on the
same diagonal and do I really want to go
Kings side not so sure about that with
this rook having the G file so you
definitely make me think twice about
things if you have this pawn on each
five instead of h6 just that small
little but important detail that's my
main suggestion I think I think that's
the one way you could really steer the
game into a different direction because
now it's a tough road ahead I don't know
if pond takes would I help out so much
more maybe it is better if you take with
your pond then this guy you could move
if you take with your beep on its your
sepan that watches over d5 and you can
maybe get this guy rolling with the f5
that's another idea take with your beep
on I don't know how to break down this
structure anymore to be honest um I saw
and dishonest by saying to be honest
right now I'm being honest before though
okay anyhow that's my main suggestion i
think it's tough road ahead now maybe
this be four move before i get my rook
to e1 if you're gonna do that maybe do
it right now and then it's like a true
PSAC i don't know yeah tough to defend i
think even though the material i would
have remaining is a bit limited but
anyhow I think h5 is certainly something
to be thinking about ok let's close